et justement malgré l'infime espoir des
centaines de familles veulent encore
croire au miracle les proches des
victimes sont à l'affût des moindres
indices par tous les new yorkais expose
des photos et lancent des avis de
recherche à manhattan le reportage de
nos envoyés spéciaux carine azzopardi et
nicolas brignon nous n'avons pas peur
être ensemble pour conjurer la douleur
et s'accrochait désespérément à l'espoir
c'est mon frère il a disparu depuis
mardi
il a été vu vivant avec le reste de ses
collègues
depuis personne ne l'a vu si quelqu'un
la moindre information
je vous en prie le vertige devant ces
centaines de visages des milliers de
proches pour qui la vie se résume à un
numéro de téléphone
on n'a pas encore de mauvaises nouvelles
alors en espère toujours
j'espère qu'il est dans un hôpital qu'on
va bientôt lui rendre visite et le
ramener à la maison
john et son fiancé au moment du crash il
se trouvait au son deuxième étage de la
deuxième tour
le champ des disparus comme une
supplique ils unissent leurs voix pour
refuser la mort jusqu'à nier l'évidence
il y a des histoires avec des gens qui
ont été enterrés dans les tremblements
de terre et ils ont survécu après
plusieurs jours sans boire et sans
manger
évidemment j'espère qu'il est vivant
mais en même temps je ne veux pas non
plus qu'ils souffrent ça s'est passé
mardi et aujourd'hui on est samedi
jusqu'à présent 159 corps à peine ont
été retrouvés comment préparez les
familles à un deuil sont des pouilles
c'est à cette question que les autorités
tentent de répondre pulvérisé certaines
victimes ont sans doute disparu pour
l'éternité et autour